Es ist eine Aliensonde.
Das ist keine wissenschaftliche, sondern eine
journalistische Analyse.
Jedenfalls, wenn wir unser Exklusiv-Interview
mit Prof.
Abraham mal auseinandernehmen, dann spricht
eigentlich alles dafür, dass es sich um ein
von einer intelligenten Spezies gefertigtes
Artefakt handeln muss.
Zwar hat sich auch bei solchen Analysen auch
die Wissenschaft schon geirrt.
Aber es sind einfach sehr viele Indizien,
die einen natürlichen Ursprung ausschließen
und auf ein künstliches Objekt schließen
lassen.
Und sie passen zusammen.
Jetzt also die Analyse bei Clixoom Science
& Fiction Hier gibt es täglich hochspannende
Science Videos.
Abonniert den Kanal, nur dann verpasst ihr
kein Video.
Herzlich willkommen!
Professor Abraham Loeb Verfasser der Studie
über das Interstellare Objekt Oumuamua war
bei uns exklusiv im Interview.
Er hat dort die These vertreten, dass es sich
bei dem ersten entdeckten interstellaren Objekt
in unserem Sonnensystem um ein künstliches
von einer außerirdischen Spezies gefertigten
Objekt handeln könnte.
Wir tragen die Fakten zusammen und kommen
zu einem ziemlich klaren Schluß.
Wenn die Wissenschaft etwas besonders schönes
oder klares entdeckt, dann gehen eigentlich
immer alle davon aus, dass es gelten muss.
Dunkle Energie und dunkle Materie sind so
ein Beispiel.
Die Erklärungen sind alle schlüssig und
schön.
Niemand zweifelt in der Wissenschaft an ihre
Existenz.
Allerdings steht der direkte Beweis noch aus.
Niemand hat Partikel und sonst etwas gefunden,
was diese dunkle Energie oder die dunkle Materie
sein könnten.
Trotzdem gibt es nur wenige, die Zweifel anmelden.
Und genauso ist bei Oumuamua.
Immer mehr Forschungsergebnisse deuten in
die Richtung eines künstlichen Objektes.
Und Professor hat eine Idee, um was es sich
handeln könnte:
“Das hat mich dazu veranlasst, die Möglichkeit
in Betracht zu ziehen, dass es vielleicht
ein Licht-Segel ist.
Und wenn ja, wurde es künstlich hergestellt
und dann stellt sich die Frage: Wer hat das
getan und ist das eine fremde Zivilisation?”
Aber was spricht dafür das Oumuamua ein solches
Lichtsegel sein könnte?
Und da ist die Studie von Abraham Loeb und
Shmuel Bialy bahnbrechend.
Sie haben nämlich eine mit einem natürlichen
Objekt unerklärliche Eigenschaft von Oumuamua
entdeckt.
Das Objekt hat beim Vorbeiflug an der Sonnen
so stark beschleunigt, wie es für ein natürliches
Objekt unmöglich ist, jedenfalls, wenn es
nicht wie bei einem Komet zu Ausgasungen kommt.
“Es gibt einige Berichte, dass nicht viel
Hitze wahrgenommen wurde.
Es gibt eine Begrenzung, wie warm dieses Objekt
war.
Dies bedeutet, dass es sich um einen sehr
guten Reflektor handelt und es kein guter
absorbierer des Sonnenlichts ist.
Interessanterweise bewegt sich dieses Objekt
jedoch in einer Flugbahn, die nicht nur durch
die Schwerkraft der Sonne geformt wird.
Es wirkt eine zusätzliche Kraft mit sehr
hoher Bedeutung.
In der Regel für Kometen kann die Verdampfung
von Eis auf der Oberfläche des Kometen einen
zusätzlichen Schub erhalten.
Das ist, was ihm den Anschein eines Kometen
gibt, aber es gibt keinen Kometenschwanz auf
diesem Objekt, und wenn es vom Kometen einen
zusätzlichen Schub gab - die Ausgasung -, dann
hätte diese Ausgasung auch die Spin-Periode
des Objekts verändert. und das konnten wir
nicht feststellen.”
Und noch etwas ist paradox und mit einem natürlichen
Objekt unerklärlich:
“Es hat eine Form, die viel extremer ist
als jeder Asteroid oder Komet, den wir gesehen
haben. und wir können das sagen, weil es
Sonnenlicht reflektiert.
Und da das Objekt nah an der Erde vorbeikgekommen
ist, konnten wir feststellen dass es sich
alle acht Stunden dreht und dass sich die
Helligkeit um etwa den Faktor 10 ändert,
was bedeutet, dass es mindestens fünfmal
länger ist als breit.”
Es wäre also wie alle Abbildungen zeigen,
extrem lang und stabförmig.
Eine Form, die wir so noch nicht in unserem
Sonnensystem gesehen haben.
Nur wenn wir Raumschiffe bauen haben sie unter
Umständen diese Form.
Und es ist extrem dünn.
Jedenfalls ist nur dann die Beschleunigung
durch die Sonne erklärbar:
“Wir schlugen vor, dass das Sonnenlicht
nur durch den Strahlungsdruck auf dieses Objekt
gedrückt werden könnte.
Damit dies effektiv ist, muss das Objekt sehr
dünn sein, weniger als einen Millimeter dick
und eine Größe von etwa 20 Metern oder mehr
haben.”
Wenn es andere intelligente Spezies da draußen
gibt, dann ist Oumuamua für Professor Loeb
nichts besonderes:
“Mein Ansatz dazu ist, dass wir so viele
Daten wie möglich vom Himmel sammeln und
keine Vorurteile haben.
Ich spreche aus Bescheidenheit, ich denke,
dass wir nicht besonders sind.
Wir wissen also, dass ein Viertel aller Sterne
einen Planeten wie die Erde hat, ungefähr
so ​​groß wie die Erde mit der richtigen
Entfernung, damit flüssiges Wasser an der
Oberfläche und die Chemie des Lebens, wie
wir sie kennen, bestehen kann.
Und wenn man für ein Viertel aller Sterne
so und so oft würfelt ...
"Milliarden mal", ja!
Milliarden Mal, dann ist es sehr wahrscheinlich,
dass es primitives Leben gibt, Mikrobienleben,
aber vielleicht auch intelligentes Leben da
draußen!
und wir sollten nicht davon ausgehen, dass
wir die Antwort vor der Suche kennen.
Wir sollten aufgeschlossen sein.
Ich denke, dass wir nichts Besonderes sind.
Ich denke, da wir hier existieren, ist es
sehr wahrscheinlich, dass es andere Zivilisationen
gibt.”
Und es gibt noch ein Indiz, das gegen ein
natürliches Objekt spricht.
Wenn es nämlich natürlich wäre, müsste
es unerklärlich viele solcher Objekte geben:
“vor etwa zehn Jahren schrieb ich einen
Artikel, in dem versucht wurde vorherzusagen,
wie viele Asteroiden, natürliche Gesteine,
das Sonnensystem von außen erreichen werden.
Und wir haben das um einen Faktor von einer
Million bis zu hundert Millionen geschätzt.
Irgendwo zwischen hundert und hundert Millionen
weniger Objekte als nötig, den Ursprung von
Oumuamua zu erklären.
Dieses Objekt gehört also zu einer Population,
die weitaus größer ist, als wir aufgrund
von Asteroiden im Sonnensystem erwartet hätten.
Die Frage ist also, woher kommt es?
Selbst wenn es natürlich ist, wissen Sie,
könnten wir etwas Neues über die Umgebung
lernen, in der es produziert wurde, und ich
denke, das wäre faszinierend.
Ich denke, wir sollten aufgeschlossen sein,
das ist mein grundlegender Punkt.”
Dies Objekt widerspricht also dem vorher von
Loeb getroffenen Annahmen, wieviel solcher
Objekte es im interstellaren Raum geben könnte.
Es ist also als natürliches Objekt extrem
unwahrscheinlich.
Trotzdem will er sich als Wissenschaftler
nicht festlegen, aber schließt die Möglichkeit
einer Aliensonde explizit ein und spricht
von einer realistischen Möglichkeit
“Nein, ich würde sagen, es ist eine Möglichkeit,
die auf dem Tisch sein sollte.
Und ich würde es als eine realistische Möglichkeit
neben einem natürlichen Ursprung betrachten.”
Und im Interview mit Professor Loeb gibt es
noch mehr Fakten, die für ein künstliches
Objekt sprechen.
Den Link zum Video gibt es hier einfach druafklicken
und wenn ihr auf keinen Fall Videos bei Clixoom
verpassen wollt zu diesem und allen anderen
Themen dann abonniert Clixoom auf englisch
hier, einfach draufklicken, denn da gibt es
auch Videopremieren, wie das Exklusiv-Interview
mit dem Havard-Professor Loeb.
Hier geht es weiter mit “There was no BigBang”
Wir sehen uns auf dem englischen Kanal von
Clixoom Stay tuned and see you soon!